[Music]
foreign
Pages time then to see what's making the
headlines with Alex Dean PR consultant
and Nancy Fielder editor-in-chief at
National world cities with us from now
until just before midnight and uh
welcome to both of you happy New Year
too haven't seen you since then and so
let's take a look at the front pages
shall we to kick off at the eye first of
all reporting that British Health
officials are hunting a new variant of
covid-19 by testing up to 2 000 Chinese
Nationals every day as they arrive at
London's Heathrow Airport The Daily Mail
meanwhile has a warning from Tory MPS
not to return to what they call face
mask Madness after Health officials
advise cold and flu victims to wear one
where's Rishi that's how the Daily Star
has led its coverage of the crisis in
the Health Service asking where the
prime minister is as the NHS crumbles
the guardian piles on the pressure with
doctors accusing the PM of being
delusional after he denied yesterday
that the NHS was in crisis the telegraph
looks ahead to Mr sunac's speech
tomorrow when he's expected to outline
his vision for the future of Britain
including making students do maths until
the age of 18. that's also the lead
story for the Times compulsory maths
until 18 for every school child the son
leads with the trial of two people
accused of robbing Olympic cycling star
Mark Cavendish and his family at knife
point in his home and the Financial
Times International Edition leads with
stock market woes for Tesla and apple as
demand for their products starts to fall
well a quick reminder by scanning the QR
code you see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers for yourself
while you listen to our guests so let's
head straight to Alex Dean PR consultant
and Nancy Fielder editor-in-chief at
National world cities and it's slightly
unusual Nancy let's kick off with the
Daily Star uh where's Rishi they say as
the NHS crumbles are bashful prime
minister is still nowhere to be seen
fears are growing for prime minister
Rishi sunag readers the urge to check
sheds and fridges in case he's trapped
inside but if we head to the times we
find out what he's been up to the big
reveal of his vision for 2023 will take
place tomorrow and in it one of the star
turns is we're told compulsory maths
until 18 for every school child
I do wonder if the Daily Star will
change their front page which will be a
tragedy because it is a brilliant and
perhaps the only funny thing that we've
seen about the NHS in the last few years
I mean to compare him to a Wally I mean
it seems completely appropriate doesn't
it and we all know what the fridge
references to we all know that some
prime ministers choose to hide and we've
seen nothing of him through all the
negotiations to all the strikes and yet
hereby comes out tomorrow with his big
plan which is presumably going to change
the entire fortunes of the country and
that is to force kids up to the age of
18 to learn maths and you know what I
actually don't think there's anything
wrong with making us education standards
higher and I think Basics such as
English and maths aren't actually done
very well necessarily but he seems to
completely noticed that there is an
exodus of teachers from the system that
the teachers are balloting to go on
strike and actually if he could do some
better calculations to get us out of the
troubles that we're in we've been much
better off than if horse children and
but talks about sort of big changes when
actually the real Basics aren't working
are they so this it seems out of tone it
seems a little bit deaf and yeah where
is Wally well the um the statement
issued by Danny Street tonight and in
fact uh revealed in the last few minutes
um says that actually the big push on
literacy since 2010 has delivered big
results uh for example in 2012 only 58
of six-year-olds were able to read words
fluently by 2019 the figure had risen to
82 and the aim is that numeracy will
match that achievement but then they go
on to say the government does not
envisage making maths a level compulsory
for all 16 year olds one rolls one's
eyes there's no way I could have done
massive Alex I don't know about you
no I think this we're a bad panel for
this aren't we because none of us did uh
maths a level like a lot of people in
the in the country but look I applaud
the desire for the country to be more
numerous in the way that the government
has campaigned for us to be uh more
literate and that desire is a positive
one uh that many of us will support it's
more important than ever potentially uh
in in the Modern Age with Computing
being as important it is coding as
lucrative as it is for people to be able
to add up and do their arithmetic but um
I my question with this one I'd
appreciate the government's not saying
that um we're going to take people to uh
all the way to a levels um to 18. but
given that we don't have compulsory
education to 18. it's a difficult um
thing to work out is it only the
children who are incompulse who are
still in education who will then be
compelled even if they don't want to uh
to do maths when traditionally 16 to 18
you've been free to choose your subjects
I for one would have struggled uh I'm
afraid between 16 and 18 uh doing more
maths than I did and I didn't
distinguish myself in my my teaching CSE
is doing it but I suppose the point is
it probably would have been for my own
good to make me do more maths and that's
part of the point of Education to compel
you to do things that you might not
enjoy the difficulty for me in working
this out is the people who are most
likely to need help are already going to
have left the educational system by the
time this requirement arrives yeah
absolutely yeah getting to master 16 was
hard enough to be fair um in the time
says this is personal for me every
opportunity I've had in life began with
the education I was so fortunate to
receive many people Nancy will be
pointing out that he had an extremely
fortunate education he also has
recognized the Practical challenges
involved
um saying that he'll commit to starting
the work of introducing maths to 18 in
this Parliament and finishing it in the
next which some might say is rather
optimistic given polling for the
conservatives right now and you might
want to talk to some teachers and some
people are actually trying to run our
education system against all the odds
before he comes up with things like this
and again it's a really great aim but
fundamentally as you've just said he
hasn't experienced a childhood like most
children growing up in Britain have and
particularly now we've seen huge
increases just in the headlines today
about the numbers of teenagers with
mental health problems and they're not
getting any support there are so many
really really important things that
aren't been dealt with and this is this
is good but it's not going to help
people and again it is going to help the
cream of the crop if it's only aimed at
children are staying onto a levels
there's no mention of apprenticeships
there's there's so much that the service
is just so out of touch for somebody to
say it helped him well great yeah having
a billionaire wife might help a lot of
people to feed their children as well
but we're not in that situation so it
needs to get real the needs to
understand the country is leading
because it doesn't feel like it does and
I I'm always a bit uncomfortable with
these comments about people's
backgrounds not least because I think
our prime minister's family story is one
of success of people coming to this
country making the best of themselves
and then applying themselves as best
they can to provide the best education
they can for their children which is I
think something that should be applauded
but moreover it's not the fault of
anybody uh where they go to school
that's their parents choice and I always
think it's rather
um sly to have a dig at where somebody
went to school even the most he scores
is the most fashionable to bash like
eating for argument's sake because in
the end they didn't choose to go there
they were sent by their parents and if
someone says they want more people to
have the advantages that they had I say
good yes I suppose the best education is
not always affordable Nancy I want to
move on if you don't mind because
um you know we've got the guardian story
and and days of headlines in fact about
the uh the crisis in the NHS Alex I'll
stick with you on this one if you don't
mind
um you know Fury really from doctors and
nurses that uh that the government
doesn't accept that this is a crisis
despite people weaving interviewed
saying this is worse than the height of
the pandemic delusional is what the the
guardian has described it as on the one
hand we do run the risk of a country as
a country of saying well this happens
every year and in the end if you if you
think that and if you say it'll all come
all right in the end or it won't be as
bad as people say because we always have
a tough winter in the NHS then one year
we will really have a very bad winter as
bad as it has been warned as being and
things will be truly terrible for our
relatives and for our loved ones so
that's the first point and you must of
course listen to the people in the
system but it's just one man's opinion
but I do think given that doctors and
nurses are amongst the most respected
professions in our country I think they
get a bit more bang for their buck when
they come more in sorrow than in Anger
to these points the guardian accurately
quotes uh this chapter chairman of the
Consultants committee Royal chronic
Resurgence excuse me the British Medical
Association as calling our prime
minister delusional but I'm afraid when
they get into that kind of rhetoric I
think they start to lose the sympathies
of some people who can see somebody
struggling and doing them as best they
can in office and you know this
guardian's got a bit of commentary on
the front Patron from this doctor which
feels like the kind of rhetoric we used
to see under Jeremy corbyn that is to
say he's going far further than Kia
starmer does in the way that people
attack the government directly and I
must I think there's probably less
effective than saying you know
we've heard so many cases on Sky News
elsewhere you've seen them you know 16
hours for someone to get help for their
wife who's had a cardiac incident who
have ultimately dies and is lifeless and
that's the only reason the ambulance
comes you know I spoke to Dr Tim
cooksley president of the society for
acute medicine today as well he said
it's got nothing to do with flu covid or
fears of strep a as Steve Barkley said
tonight it's to do with Staffing levels
and the Staffing levels have been bad
for a long time and they're getting
worse because of pay and the disparate
offering substandard care
um Nancy you know crisis or no crisis do
you feel the government needs to
recognize the situation that our NHS
workers are finding themselves in now
anybody who is not angry at this
situation is not going to have an NHS in
5 10 20 years time how can you not be
angry just personally I know an 87 year
old who was stuck in a bath injured 87
called the ambulance was told it with 15
hours I spoke to 101 year old today
whose daughter called an ambulance at
9am and they came at half past midnight
anybody who is not angry does not
understand how serious this is we need
as a country to come together behind our
Health Service behind the professionals
who run it behind the people who look in
the eyes of the relatives who've lost
loved ones because the NHS is not
capable of doing its job and we need to
come behind the staff who say they don't
want to work in the NHS because they're
not respected and they're not paid
enough until if you don't understand
that the debate is dead and it feels
pretty much like the government doesn't
understand that well let's move on to um
the eye and a related story in fact in
the daily mail
um first of all some eyebrow raising
that Chinese Travelers are told they
don't need to isolate if they're found
to be positive with covid today and here
is the eye suggesting that we're testing
to find China's next covert variant um
explain this one then Alex for us if you
can well of course we don't require
isolation for anybody with KB anymore
people may choose to isolate either
um because they don't want to infect
others or they don't want to if they've
got vulnerable loved ones and so forth
they may choose to stay away from them
but we don't require people to isolate
so it would be very peculiar to single
out a single race to do that I think
that the most significant concern whilst
it does seem we're behind other
countries in testing people uh when they
get off the aircraft they've had
something that the government's going to
start doing at least in a small way
um very soon what I think is the most
significant thing from this story is the
discussion of the frustration of the
authorities in our country and others
about the trans lack of transparency on
data coming out from China about what's
happening there and the variants that
they have it's the same kinds of
criticisms that we heard about the
origins of kovid in the first place the
same kinds of criticisms that got
Australia into such a dispute with uh
the Chinese and that I think is going to
be the thing in the end not how we treat
individual Travelers but of course in
the end aren't to blame for what's
happening it's the systemic lack of
trust that's developed with the Chinese
government in not just closing what's
happening with kovid that I think is the
biggest thing about this story yes
that's very interesting and um I say the
Daily Mail is connected let's not return
to face masks Madness
um Tory MP's warning against what
they're calling the dystopian return of
dystopian face masks after Health Chiefs
urged cold and flu sufferers to wear one
we know that um you know flu covid-19
strep a is around all of us know someone
who's been sick and here we have here
Health secretary Steve Barkley blaming
that for the pressures on the NHS but
nonetheless to Tory MPS
um it's not somewhere they want to
return to you Nancy
it's not here we go again with police
people using their political views and
trying to gain popularity going in the
face of advice from Health experts and
the clues in the word expert isn't it it
doesn't do anybody any harm wearing
masks we all are desperately concerned
about our NHS and the stuff they're
trying to run it and as you said we all
know people whose Christmases were
ruined whose holidays have been ruined
because they're seriously ill
um with diseases that perhaps spread
less if we wore masks it seems a logical
thing and perhaps it can't be enforced
but actually I know a lot of people are
already starting to think this way
anyway but again it it's not the experts
we're listening to and it really should
be well that wasn't the only message
just quickly Alex from the UK Health
security agency's Susan Hopkins advising
adults to try to stay home when unwell
um and children too um do you um think
that is a good message to push even if
you don't want Facebook look there's a
lot of wisdom in being polite and
thinking that coughs and sneezes spread
diseases and you should use the
handkerchief and if you want to to use a
mask but I've always it would be funny
if it weren't so sad that some don't
seem to realize people make
recommendations from their various
different professions and in the end the
people that make decisions are those
that we elect because they're
accountable to us if we just thought
that we should say as soon as we hear
the word expert we'll do what they say
we wouldn't be a democracy at all would
we okay Alex Nancy stay there plenty
more still to talk about including the
guardian which picks up on our lead
story tonight the woman who lied about a
rape case found guilty more than that to
come
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
Press preview with me once again Alex
Dean PR consultant and Nancy Fielder
editor-in-chief at National World Series
welcome back to both of you
um we head now to our lead story Alex
and um you know some people might
remember the Ferrari the protests the
horror at some of the scandals
surrounding so-called Asian grooming
gangs uh one 22 year old woman from
Barrow and furnace had suggested she was
a victim but today has been found that
she in fact perverted the course of
Justice tried to uh tell us more if you
can but that's right and of course Anna
she didn't just say that she was a
victim it was a crowdfunding effort that
raised tens of thousands of pounds for
her
um and there was an enormous campaign
more than a hundred thousand people
signed up to on social media demanding
Justice for her and people who tell lies
like this uh I'm afraid undermine the
case of real rape victims each and every
time they do it and it is right that
they are prosecuted and dealt with
firmly at one point was worth making
briefly which is of course whilst pretty
much all rapists are men
um not all victims are women there are
plenty of men I'm afraid in this country
who are raped by other men too and this
is a something that's terribly
underreported especially in our prisons
because of the sense of Shame quite
wrongly and misplaced on the part of the
victims involved in those cases but in
any case those who lie and say that they
have been raped by somebody when they
haven't undermined the justice system
undermine victims and it's quite right
that they're dealt with harshly indeed
so
um move on to the front of the Ft one of
those newspapers covering a Ukrainian
attack on Russian service personnel and
this is the Ferrari in Russia or indeed
the sadness in Russia if you look at
these pictures of of women laying
flowers in tribute to some of the
service Personnel who died in in the
dombas region and a statement tonight
from Russia's defense Ministry Nancy
suggesting that they now acknowledge
that 89 soldiers died in that attack
certainly Ukraine believes that the
figure could be in the hundreds but was
one always wonders if episodes like this
are some sort of turning point in a war
as bloody as this Ukrainian conflict is
I think you've got to hope that it is a
turning point and look these we heard
the reports about Russians being forced
to go and fight there aren't many people
who actually want to join another
certainly aren't many Mothers Daughters
everybody who wants to lose members of
the family you've got to feel awfully
sorry for the people who've lost
relatives nobody's winning here are they
there is no winners there are just
families that have been absolutely
destroyed and let's hope this really is
a turning point and it's hard to know if
actually the 89 people that is even the
true figure because it seems to change
and as you've said it's certainly more
that the Ukraine are claiming that
hundreds are dead so it's hard to know
really right now isn't it well I'm in
total Fury from from Russian bloggers
about this Alex has to be said on
Telegram and other services used by them
um the Russians tonight are saying that
those held responsible for having so
many people in one space will be held to
account and blame unauthorized use of
personal mobile phones for allowing
ukrainians to pinpoint their location
yes that looks to be one of the
techniques used by the ukrainians with
help from others to identify their
targets of course on the one hand I
admire Nancy's sense of humanity and no
man is an island and these Russians have
been these individual Russians have been
compelled uh to fight on behalf of a
monster but in the end Ukraine has been
unlawfully invaded we are doing our best
to help the ukrainians repel Invaders
and if somebody's going to die I would
rather we're a Russian soldier than
anybody else I've for one hope for the
end of this conflict soon but uh it
seems it's not going to come about
unless Putin continues to be defeated
again and again on the battlefield so
that's what we've got to try to help the
ukrainians to do Alex Dean Nancy Fielder
thank you so much to both of you